this is a production of Cornell
University
I am located at the tree fruit Research
Lab in Wenatchee Washington we are a
relatively small facility on a small
Washington State University campus
called the tree fruit Research &
Extension Center WSU has eight permanent
permanent faculty at that location we
have six scientists at our location we
used to have seven we just had a
retirement two weeks ago that position
is not being filled the way of the world
as we know it we have two pathologists
at the location myself working on soil
borne diseases and Larry Kushi who works
on fire blight and for post harvest
physiologists my program comes under the
auspices of the methylbromide
alternatives program within ARS one
funny thing the tree fruit industry in
Washington State has never used methyl
bromide and my program comes under the
methyl bromide alternatives program for
managing their predominant soil borne
disease being replant disease they've
used chloropicrin and teal on floor
pikmin very effectively for the past 30
years so just how government works
sometimes but that's the story um today
I'd like to talk about our program on on
bioaccumulation and kind of looking at
the reality of whether or not bio
fumigation is all about chemistry or
whether or not there are other factors
involved in the capacity of this process
to yield disease oppression now if we
take the definition of biofuel agent as
put forth by John kirkegaard back in 93
it was specifically designed to to
describe this process soil-borne pests
suppression arising specifically through
the liberation of isothiocyanates from
hydrolysis of glucosinolates that are
contained within brassicas ee plant
residues so it was a very specific
process that he was describing now that
term since then has certainly been
co-opted to describe a lot of different
processes which yield disease
suppression but specifically this is the
definition that that john utilize and
it's what i'm going to focus on today
when i talk about
by a few gates if we look at the
chemistry based paradigm bio fumigation
in response to brass KC plant residue
amendments is the following so you're
growing your mustard or canola whatever
the Brassica might be you then
incorporate that into the soil profile
the Brassica residue possesses
glucosinolates through the activity of
the enzyme myrosinase you have
hydrolysis to yield isothiocyanates as
well as other hydrolytic chemistry's
which then directly yield pests
suppression whether it be insects fungi
weeds nematodes etc that's the chemistry
pace paradigm however there is evidence
in the literature to suggest that there
are alternative mechanisms that lead to
pest suppression first of all there's
the example of Disease Control being
attained with residues that yield
chemistry's that possess little if any
antimicrobial activity which would
suggest a different mechanism secondly
there's been the observation that
disease suppression increased for weeks
after the active chemistry was lost
either through microbial breakdown or
volatilization so we were actually
observing an increase in disease
suppression over time even though the
act of chemistry had been lost from the
system thirdly pathogen or parasite
suppression is obtained irrespective of
glucosinolate content that is contained
within the residue that was utilized and
lastly disease suppression only
functioning in a biologically intact
soil system so these observations would
suggest that perhaps something other
than chemistry in certain situations is
leading to pest suppression
so what I'd like to go through today is
to describe some specific examples of
pest control in response to Brassica
residues in a Soylent system to go over
some evidence that we generated
suggesting a biological mechanism is
involved the possible functional groups
of that biology that are involved in
that pest suppression and moving it to
the field looking at our application of
this material for the control of apple
replant disease in our system okay now
we don't utilize the green manures we
utilize Brassica sea seed meal as our
residue for incorporation into soil
profiles now these seed meals are a
byproduct of the oil extraction process
whether it be oil used in the for
biodiesel or edible oils the farmer on
the right here is actually a wheat
farmer on the Palouse region of Eastern
Washington he grows to Napa Salva to
generate his biodiesel he sells his seed
meal as a fertilizer this material is
about 6% n 2% P 1 or 2% sulfur so that's
the material that we're utilizing in our
program the first patho system that I'd
like to describe in our work has to do
with the control of Rhizoctonia Salani
which causes Rhizoctonia root rot of a
variety of different plants and the seed
meal being Brassica napus or canola meal
or rapeseed meal in our system
resurrector nestled on e85 is a dominant
member of the Rhizoctonia group which
causes disease in other plant systems
there are other Rhizoctonia x' which
cause significant soil borne diseases on
the far left he under the control you
see the types of root damage that can be
caused by this particular pathogen but
we get very effective control of project
owners and Lonnie with Brassica Navis
seed meal and that's very interesting
because louisa minnici and her coworkers
that belong
Italy at the International excuse me the
industrial crops Research Center in
Bologna have demonstrated that the
dominant glucosinolate through butanol
hookah simulate the hydrolysis products
that emanate from that particular
chemistry do not have activity against
rods like Tonio Salani so why are we
achieving Disease Control through our
beam APIs seed meal that's the question
that we wanted to entertain so in our
studies we utilize two different seed
meals to look at whether or not
glucosinolate would have any impact on
the disease control that we achieved we
have Brassica napus cultivar dwarf Essex
which has a Lucas inlay content of 113
micro mole per gram material so
relatively cawing and another Brassica
napus which actually I just purchased
from a local supply store a canola meal
which had dramatically lower levels of
glucosinolate 21.8 Micra mol program and
we introduced the seed meal at a rate of
either 0.1% or 1% incubated those soils
for a period of four to eight weeks
introduce the pathogen and looked at
what types of Disease Control we
obtained what was there interesting is
that we got very effective disease
control on the y-axis we have percent
our Salani root infection you can see
our control we're up about 16% even at a
concentration of 0.1 percent on a weight
weight basis we significantly reduce
disease at a 1% seed meal amendment we
basically almost abolish disease but it
did not matter what the glucosinolate
content of the material was we got
virtually the exact same level of
disease suppression again just
suggestive of the fact that something
other than bio fumigation the liberation
of hydro have glucosinolate hydrolysis
products was responsible for whatever we
were seeing well the next question is is
an active microbial community required
for this phenomenon and to test that we
had a series of studies where our soil
treatments were either
included Brassica napa seed meal and and
either we didn't add the seed meal so
that would be the no we did add the seed
meal which was yes we pasteurized the
seed meal to make certain that we
weren't interest introducing some
biological entity on the seed meal
itself and we conducted it either in a
native soil system in intact soil system
or a pasteurized soil system where we
obviously reduced the activity of that
microbial community what we found is
that in our control which was the no
seed meal amendment native soil system
we had about forty five percent
root infection we demonstrable eat
lowered that root infection by adding
the seed meal to a native soil system
but it did not matter whether or not we
pasteurized that seed meal prior to
introduction we got the same level of
disease suppression suggesting that in
fact we're not introducing something on
the seed meal from a biological
perspective that's resulting in the
disease control that we achieve if we
add seed meal to a pasteurized soil
system we have no disease control
whatsoever in fact we've elevated
disease quite significantly
basically we're introducing rise off to
a system which says thank you very much
you've provided me with a nice growth
substrate and I'll go from there so an
active soil biology is required for the
for the disease control that we're
achieving under the situation well then
you move on what is the functional
biology and if we look at a field trial
that we conducted one element that stuck
out quite nicely was the streptomyces
community so in this field trial they
have a seed meal amendment nebraska napa
seed meal teal and c-17 soil fumigation
in our control in the control soils our
populations are between 10 to the fifth
and 10 to the six CFU our streptomyces
numbers if we look at what happens in
our seed meal amended soils within four
weeks of application our streptomyces
numbers are about two to three orders of
magnitude higher than in the non treated
control soil those numbers are
maintained
over the course of this experiment which
ran 12 weeks but we found that these
numbers are actually maintained over a
period of 18 months in our orchard soils
simply by a one-time treatment and so
this community was an interest to us
well we know that streptomyces produce a
variety of different secondary
metabolites which have antibiotic
activity if we look at the traditional
plate assay that we see in a lot of the
biological control work we have plated
Rhizoctonia suwanee on the left side of
that auger surface we plate the
streptomyces strain of interest on the
right and you look for the development
of a zone of inhibition okay well it was
interesting in that if you look at the
proportion of isolates recovered from
the seed meal amended soil with relative
to their capacity to actually inhibit
rhizoctonia you see that the numbers
increase dramatically from about 25
percent in our control soil to over 70
percent in our seed meal amended soil so
ask the question is it Ana bios's and
specifically streptomyces producing and
about strains that are responsible for
the disease control that we're observing
long story short don't think so
first of all if we look at growth of
rise Auk through a soil column which has
been amended with B nappa seed meal we
see absolutely no suppression of
Highfill growth okay and secondly we
don't really see a relationship between
the capacity of these isolates to
antagonize our Salani in vitro and
disease suppression and just to
demonstrate that association here we
have a graph of various isolates of
streptomyces on the x-axis we have
percent rhizoctonia Salani inhibition on
an in vitro plate asset you have many
isolates such as s1 the one on the far
left which completely inhibit the fungus
we have other isolates like the next one
SCR too
which do not inhibit the fungus
whatsoever so if we just look at at four
isolates - so we got 56 95 in green and
SCR - in green completely lack the
capacity to inhibit our Salani to other
isolates s15 and 56 92 they actually
inhibit the fungus quite nicely in vitro
if we look at disease again on the
x-axis a percentage of the no treatment
control so a hundred percent is the
control anything below that would be
disease suppression okay we see that scr
- we have very little disease 5695 very
little disease in fact disease has been
reduced 90 to 95 percent by two isolates
which demonstrate no ability to
antagonize this fungus in contrast s 15
which has a very nice level of in vitro
inhibition is not controlling disease
whatsoever and 56 92 and we topped out
at 100% here 100% of the control as far
as disease in fact because I didn't want
to change the scale we're looking at
300% in this instance the disease
development with this antibiotic
producing strain was three times what we
observed in no treatment control so we
don't really see that association
between the capacity of these isolates
to inhibit growth of the fungus and
disease suppression well we look at a
different mechanism and that being
induced resistance whether or not that's
the activity that these streptomyces are
having on this phenomenon and so in
these assays we just split the root
system of a gala seedling we grow half
of that root system in a comb which is
infested with the pathogen the other
half of that root system was either
amended with the seed meal or not
amended with the seed milk okay and then
we look for development of disease only
on the left cone the root system going
in that left hand huh and what we saw is
that in fact if we added the seed meal
to their cone on the right hand side we
were able to suppress disease
development
in the left-hand-side cone there's a
significant reduction in disease in both
of these experiments suggesting that we
are inducing some host defense responses
through that seed meal application well
the question then needs to be addressed
are the streptomyces in these beam app
as amended soils a part of that biology
that's contributing to this induction of
resistance and so we did the same study
but instead of adding the B nappa seed
meal to one side of the system
we added individual isolates of
streptomyces recovered from these seed
meal amended soils and looked at the
same response
so our positive control is on top here
at 0.5% seed meal no streptomyces added
to the soil system we had about 22% root
infection our negative control is a
pasteurized soil system no streptomyces
added we had about 47% boot infection
within those pasteurized soil systems
then we added individual isolates of
streptomyces and we can see that all
four isolates in this particular example
were capable of suppressing disease
relative to the control and three out of
those four isolates gave us disease
suppression which were equivalent to
that attained in response to the beam at
the sieve element so overall in this
story we believe that control in
response control of Rhizoctonia rubra in
response to Brassica not the seed meal
amendment is not a chemistry based model
but in fact is biology dependent and is
dependent upon these streptomyces which
are amplified in response to the beam at
the seed meal amendment well a different
system a different path of system one
that I'm sure Eric will love is Pythium
and the different seed meal that we
employed in this system is brassica
juncea
otherwise known as oriental mustard now
B juncea does produce an active
chemistry it's called allyl
isothiocyanate which is
in response to Lucas and Olay hydrolysis
and we know that in fact at least at
timepoint zero production of allyl
isothiocyanate is important in the
suppression of Pythium we also know that
this chemistry is depleted from the soil
system within two to three days
depending upon how much seed meal you
add to that system now the question that
we had is when Pythium is introduced
post this AITC generation period can we
control disease and the reason that we
asked that question is that all of our
orchards in the Pacific Northwest are
under irrigation okay 12 to 24 hour sets
our irrigation waters are loaded with
Pythium and Phytophthora and so we're
looking at whether or not we can develop
a soil system which is suppressive to
the Rhian ovulation of these soils over
time so looking at a long term
suppression whether or not we're capable
of inducing that long term suppression
the series of studies that were
initiated with B juncea seed meal we
added to our orchard soil we incubated
those soils for two to twelve weeks
we then pasteurized half of those seat
meal treated soils the other half was
left in its native state we then
introduced Pythium Avaris aureum which
is one of many different species of
Pythium that affect apple and then we
conducted our plant biomass A's what we
found is that irrespective of the
incubation period we were able to in
fact induce a system which was
suppressive to disease development on
the far left we have our control that's
root infection caused by P AB AB rap
force aureum we're up around 25% 2/8 and
12 weeks after seed meal amendment we
add our pathogen back into the system
and we have dramatic reductions in
disease relative to the control
we conduct the same a say in a
pasteurized soil system you can see that
we've abolished disease suppression in
fact at two weeks incubation period
we've actually enhanced disease
development because again the AIT C
which is an act of chemistry is long
gone from the system and so this this
seed meal is still acting as a substrate
for the organisms that are residing in
that system including the Pythium that
we've added to the soil system
well we believe that AITC actually is
somehow involved in the process it's not
directly contributing to disease
development at least for the long-term
suppression but it may be contributing
some other response and the reason why
we believe that is because we cannot
generate the same type of disease
control under the same conditions with
other seed meals other Brassica seed
meals that we've tried so if we use
canola meal or a rapeseed meal or white
mustard we don't elicit this response
they have different chemistry's all
right so we believe that perhaps Ali
life so far sunny is somehow
contributing to the phenomenon even if
it's not a direct contribution to the
long-term disease depression so in this
study we've infested the soil for we've
amended the soil and infested it with
pithy amount of a purse aureum two weeks
after amendment now we bag in one
instance where bagging that soil and the
other instance were actually incubating
that soil in an open condition the
reason why we're baggy is because in the
field we would typically tarp these
soils okay to increase the concentration
active concentration of AITC
so that's why we use the bagging
approach here now if we incubate at
those soils in the open we did get
disease suppression from over 55% down
to about 35 percent but if we had
incubated those soils in an enclosed
condition which should have concentrated
the AITC activity we see that in fact
disease suppression is demonstrable a
lower okay
another way to look at the role of a ITC
possibly in this phenomenon is to
inactivate the Marat sanae's activity so
that we get no AITC production in the
first place and so we just heat our our
seed meal inactivate the enzyme no a ITC
is generated and what we found ok these
soils were incubated for 8 weeks prior
to introduction of the pathogen again in
our seed we lamented soil which again
we're using a native seed meal in this
instance we get effective disease
control but if we use the denatured the
heat denatured seed meal we do not
attain disease control and again we
actually enhance disease development
which is suggestive of a ITC having some
role even if it's not direct is having
some role in this system but it's
through a biological mechanism so what
is that biological mechanism well if we
look at simply what's growing on our
soils after seed meal amendment if we
look at what's Inc what grows on that
soil system if we incubate that soil in
the open you have one type of fungal
growth emergent if you look at what
grows in that enclosed system it's a
very different fun local community and
the pathologists probably know what that
guy is if we look at what that community
is based upon different methodologies
whether it be array analysis tea RFLP
analysis or simply doing clone libraries
and sequencing we find that the
community that develops in the enclosed
system is dominated by various species
of trichoderma and trichoderma obviously
are known as very good biocontrol agents
of things like Pythium in the open
condition we have a community which is
dominated by more torella Alpina which
to my knowledge has no effect on other
than perhaps a competitive effect in the
system
so a different biology involved in this
phenomenon relative to the rise like
tunas Milani story but just to kind of
summarize that element the role of
biology in Brassica sea mule induce
disease suppression is going to vary
with the target pathogen in some systems
biology may have no intrinsic role in
the disease we observe the functional
biology community if there is a
biological entity contributing to
disease suppression it's going to vary
with the target pathogen now the
operative mechanism whether it be
chemistry or biology is also going to
vary in a temporal manner at times zero
chemistry may be very involved but at
timepoint
some time point in the future it may
have no role at all okay so one last
pest to look at is weed suppression and
this is kind of one of those
observations that let let you scratching
your head you have two trials here when
it's sent send who knew Quebec
which was an orchard trial and a study
in around Oh Washington which was a
rootstock trial and I don't know if you
can barely see those yellow tags that's
where the tree is where the stick is or
the root stock is it's kind of having a
tough time out competing the weeds but
interestingly enough in the plots that
were treated with the bean APIs seed
meal we're observing some weed
suppression now again that was very
interesting because bean APIs the
hydrolysis of glucosinolate does not
yield any herbicidal activity as far as
we know so again what can we base this
observation upon that was the question
well here's just some some visuals the
biomass of weeds collected from those
plots you can see the control quite high
but our again our seed meal or our seed
meal with with a solar treatment
significantly lower and it just so
happened that I mean you have to use
your imagination
right there seem to be somewhat of an
inverse relationship between weed
biomass and our Pythium densities okay
so weed biomass goes down as Pythium
density goes up well we know that
Pythium is a organism which causes you
know pre-emergence and post emergence
damping off could this have contributed
to what we were observing well if we
look at three different seed meals again
bean apis be juncea and Senatus alba or
white mustard they have differential
impacts on Pythian populations okay
both bean apis and synapses alba
stimulate Pythium okay by orders of
magnitude in in virtually every soil
that we look at
whereas brassica juncea has a depressing
impact on that same population and so
what we wanted to do is look at what the
relative impacts of these seed mills
were given their impact on Pythium what
the relative impacts of these heat meals
were on weed emergence so this these
data are our mean plant plant emergence
per cell and we had five plants per cell
okay so the maximum would have been five
if we look at pigweed and we applied
these with and without rid of em now
Ritter mill is a material which has
activity against all my C's okay so it's
going to suppress Pythium and things
like bike hock through if we look at
Brassica napus
with the no ridda mill you can see that
we've depressed weed emergence but
snappa salvo we've depressed weed
emergence with brassica juncea we have
not if we apply Ritter mill we increase
weed emergence in both the bean APIs and
soon APIs all the treatments suggesting
a Pythium is somehow having a role in
the disease of the weed suppression that
we're observing if we look at wheat now
granted wheats not a wheat but it's a
grass so that's our experimental model
here we saw the exact same response that
is be nappa Cincinnatus alba to seed
meals that induce elevation of pit
you are reducing plant emergence we
apply rate of mill and we abolish that
weed control okay
so we believe that in in in this system
under some circumstances we are getting
pit humans involved in the weed
suppression that we're observing just to
show you visually what that looks like
this is a pasteurized soil system with
and without rid Emil obviously there's
there's no difference here beam APIs and
APIs Alaba grid amil on the right-hand
side of each picture no ridda mill on
the left and you can see that we have
dramatically enhanced we didn't plant
emergence in the system so to summarize
that that that weed story certainly the
efficacy of these seed meal treatments
is going to be dependent upon where you
source your C meal from what's what's
the plant species that it was derived
from also weed species composition is
going to have major impacts on whether
or not this strategy will will be
effective for weed control the Pythium
species resident to that soil system is
going to be very important what we've
seen in one orchard where Pythium hetero
thala command piteå matter antheridium
which are weakly virulent Pythium
species we get very low efficacy of weed
suppression through a Brassica napa seed
mmmm in an another orchard system where
Pythium ultimen eighths we get very good
weed control escapees can literally be a
very large problem if for whatever
reason these weeds avoid the activity of
Pythium and emerge from that system
you're going to end up with very large
plants you're adding 6% n with these
seed meal amendments and you know the
lone survivor is going to take advantage
of that nutrient source
so now I'd like to get into the
application of our CDL amendments for
controlling the phenomenon of Apple
replant disease and I realize it's
debatable but from our system the cause
of biology that we're looking at
involves various fungal pathogens
including cilinder carbon rhizoctonia
very oh my seats like photographer and
Pythium and lesion nematode prattling as
penetrance if you look at the damage
that the phenomenon can cause we have a
on the far left we have galas on m26
those trees or trees are in their second
leaf if we look at the fumigation
response you can see that there's quite
a healthy difference between those two
shots okay the way that we apply it is
we typically use an automatic ation
although we're trying to use springtime
applications with seed meal we then
incorporate it into the soil profile we
tarp it with a virtually impermeable
film for about for about a week
remove that we then have a plant back
period of four to six weeks depending
upon the soil system in other systems
it's going to have to be much longer
from what we have discovered to date
we've done ten trials six orchard
locations each trial running three to
six years which why is why no one
seeking tenure should work on the system
the general conclusions are that
individual seed meals used independently
will always fail from our experience the
failure can always be traced back to
biology of the system and site to site
variability may be soil physical
properties but also may be soil biology
induced
this one was on m26 the most recent ones
are all on g11 so individual seed meals
always fail this was a trial initiated
in 2004 who was wrapped up in 2009 again
we used three different seed meals
methan oxen which is riddim mill alone
or Tila and c-17 was our fumigant in
this system if we look at increase in
radial growth excuse me the tree trunk
diameter over the course of that time
period the line in red the one which is
above all others is our fumigation
treatment and you can see that all other
treatments failed to elicit a positive
growth response the control is the black
line on the bottom but there was no
significant difference in the seed meal
treatments relative to the control and
there was no difference between the
rhythm mill application and the control
if we look at fruit yields so here our
brassica juncea Navis Senatus alba be
juncea the bee nap is no different from
the control significantly lower than the
fumigation the snap is alba c treatment
the seed meal treatment the white
mustard we did have a significant
increased relative that can control but
no different excuse me
significantly less than soil fumigation
so individual seed meals and our hands
have always failed however if we combine
those seed meal treatments with a post
plant application of ridda mill we yield
different response you can see in this
figure the two seed meals brassica
juncea and bat Brassica and Senatus alba
though the growth of trees grown in
those soils are equivalent to what was
obtained with pre plants so a fumigation
with bean apis plus ridda mil
significantly greater than the control
over the period of time if we look at
yields all three seed meals with the
post plant rudimental treatment whereas
efficacious as pre plant soil fumigation
in increasing yields relative
to the no treatment control now for
synapses Alba and Brassica napus we kind
of expected that due to the fact that we
know what impacts those seed meals have
on Pythium I mean you're you're
elevating populations two to three
orders of magnitude by applying these
seed meals and ridah mill will control
that what was surprising to us was the
bee juncea treatment because we know be
juncea controls Pythium quite nicely
what was the impact of metal axle in
that system
well we went back and looked at that
phenomenon basically we found that the
trees grown in beach NCSC meal treated
soils without the rhythm of treatment
were 100% infected by fight African
VEVRAA so the response in that situation
was due to Phytophthora coming in and
controlling that through the application
of ridda mill well obviously that system
is not going to be suitable for organic
orchard systems and so we've looked at
trying to formulate seed meals based
upon their activity against the spectrum
of pathogens that were interested in
this is one trial conducted in a
commercial organic orchard we applied
the seed meal in April of 2010 we
removed the tarp one week later and we
planted that site with Donegal on g11 a
month later what we found was actually
from my perspective quite astonishing
the seed meal treatment is outperforming
everything by a long shot
the FEMA Gatien treatment not so much I
mean there's a little separation this
year but whether or not that's anything
of interest is really questionable and
that's it's a high organic matter soil
but it's a sandy loam you know but we
think we have some biological basis for
this if we look at initial suppression
of lesion nematode we can see that both
pre plant fumigation and the seed meal
amendment which is on the right
significantly lowered lesion nematode
numbers during that initial collection
period if we look at a year later we see
that in our in our
seed meal treatment I mean it's a
fumigation treatment the peep and trans
numbers have rebounded quite nicely and
I think we just have a more resilient
system in our in our seed meal soil
treatment and we saw this exact same
pattern with regards to Pythium
populations Azure pity root infection in
this particular soil system we actually
did obtain some very nice weed control
this is the exception rather than the
rule this was two months after planting
you can see our seed meal treatment we
basically have very little in the way of
weed biomass relative to our control
treatment had another location the same
seed meal formulations but we varied the
application date either in the fall
prior to planting or the spring of
planting again the tarps were removed
after one week after seed meal amended
and we planted this site with gala g11
this is September of the year of
planting when we applied the seed meal
formulation in the autumn prior to
planting the trees are actually looking
pretty good if we applied the seed meal
in the spring of the year we were quite
capable of getting some very good weed
control with the trees being the weeds
in this particular instance we have some
very good photo toxicity in this system
the difference between this system and
the previous soil is that we have 11.2%
organic matter in this soil system we
had about four four and a half percent
organic matter in the other soil have
very low biological activity in this
system compared to the previous orchard
system so you you probably are dealing
with a time frame needed to break down
some of the like ionic thiocyanate which
have herbicidal activity that's the
guest at this point in time so in a
sandy soil system like this I think we
were limited to a autumn prior to
planting application in order to be
certain that we don't end up with that
type of response this was July of this
year just looking at what the trees are
expressing at this point in time
our controls on the fall let far-left
not doing so hot our fumigation and and
seat meal formulations what they're
looking like at this point in time we
look at growth here's our check are no
treatment control and all of our seat
meal combinations are doing just as well
as our pre plant soil fumigation I will
say that all of those trees that were
expressing phyto toxicity those have
been eliminated from this data set those
trees no longer exist in the orchard so
just to summarize pests and pathogens
control achieved and response to seed
meal amendments I think it's pretty
evident that they're probably involving
multiple active mechanisms the dominant
functional mechanism is certainly going
to vary with a lot of different factors
including but this the plant source of
the seed meal and that certainly the
target pest or pathogen that you're
interested in and although itcs are
generally thought to be involved in
these phenomena I think in certain
instances glucosinolate hydrolysis
products don't have much of a role if
any gain the pest depression that we're
observing and I think in our system with
developing an alternative strategy for
controlling replant disease we really
need to to know that the spectrum of
activity of these seed meals their mode
of action and in impact and influence of
the soil system itself on the various
attributes whether it be issues of phyto
toxicity whether or not the biology
that's resident into that system has any
potential to generate a disease
suppressive effect we really need to
have a broader base of knowledge in the
biology of a system to use these
materials effectively and that's the
people the group Mike Cohen was who's
now he's on the faculty at Sonoma State
was very involved in the rise off work
who deed to where Kuhn who was a former
graduate student was very involved in
the Pythian work and Lori Hoagland who's
now on the faculty at Purdue was
involved with the weed work thanks very
much
just just the old tree road
the agreement I think the problem that
the problem that I have as far as grower
adoption you know there are several
issues one being the fact that you can
grow these trees after seed meal
amendment with no fertility inputs for
three years that's a real benefit
secondly you don't have to grow a crop
you don't have to the costs involved in
growing the crop and the ITC's if that's
a functional mechanism the ITC that's
generated in response to this versus a
green manure our orders of magnitude
different that's why we gone that
approach we we have not we have not
I think the time of the year probably
that mechanism would be circumvented
because we're applying them either
you know October or September of the
year within a week you know the system
is being evacuated in the springtime
we're talking April there are conditions
I I mean I'm not gonna say no but I
would have reservations in stating that
it is I guess because we tried
solarization in our system and we have
not even it even in the summer getting
temperatures at the 10 to 20 centimeter
depth up to 30 to 35 see it's really
tough even with adding something into it
well I think that there's a lot of
questions in there because people if
you're looking at at general biology you
know we know that that certain pathogens
are suppressed quite well through the
term general suppression and there's
specific suppression right they're
different typically involving different
modes of action things like like Pythium
for instance typically are controlled
quite nicely due to due to enhanced
competition so enhanced microbial
activity whereas other pathogens perhaps
not we have not looked directly at
general suppression models in in in what
we're studying
I guess because we're fairly confident
that the organisms that we've identified
today are actually functioning in our
system and I guess it's just a level of
interest and where one goes so no I I
can't address that issue specifically
presented when I'm struggling with here
trying to
with the organic amendment itself and
what role might the isothiocyanates
relative to the organic amendment so
yeah have you been able to decouple
those in a way where you can look at
okay what's happening with a nice of
thiocyanate watch is it pushing to Micro
microbial communities in a certain
direction that I think it's it's
definitely dependent upon the seed meal
that you're talking about I mean I don't
think there's any question that would be
juncea it's pushing that system we know
that the AITC is functional at time zero
but if we do time for studies you can
see that if you add your pathogen 24
hours after you've added your seed meal
you won't get any disease control at
time zero you will so you can separate
it out right there as far as how long
that functional mechanism is operating
but as far as generating I think I still
think the AITC is driving that fungal
shift in that in that beat Jun see
amended soil the other thing is that if
you look at the streptomyces component
with regards to be napa seed meal I
think that the seed meal itself is that
whatever carbon
type is in that seat meal is selecting
for the enhancement of step demise these
populations and it just so happens that
these Steve meals have back in the
literature were used as a base for
culturing streptomyces something there
they're all about 6% it is
you won't get don't get me wrong you are
but what we do in our field trials
anyway is to only fertilize the control
and the fumigated blocks we don't
fertilize the seed meal treated blocks
at all just to address that particular
point 120 pounds per acre
it's a really complicated system right
but I'm curious why and your summary
slide you didn't list that unit light
for the rootstock we know that those two
different prizes no personal community
that's just another whole level of
complexity your own date shows that I
never would you went to g11 no question
no question yeah yeah rootstock is is
certainly going to play a significant
role in overall management and it's nice
to have material that actually can
provide some level of tolerance to the
organisms that we're dealing
yeah that's a really good question the
price is actually going off because
there's more and more interest in it
when I started out it was about 400
pounds
I've excuse me corn at all is the acre
that's probably up close to a thousand
now we're working with a company down in
Santa Cruz California on the
formulations and that's basically what
they're going for they're targeting the
strawberry industry instead of
strawberry growers are you know they're
more progressive and a little bit more
flush with the cash so they're willing
to go that way and in California based
upon the regulatory nature of the place
yeah you're probably going to have to I
mean if you look at Township caps forty
low and unless you have a critical use
exemption for methyl bromide your you've
got to find something else
the track eternal response so is trying
to adjust in here resistant it is yep
yep it's it's actually amongst the fungi
we've tested it's easily the most
resistant to a ITC
salùte departments controlled very well
with with Vicenza yeah so there's just
wide variation in sensitive yes yeah if
you look at for instance the 50 and
profiles vary quite dramatically in
their sensitivity to a ITC yeah I don't
know how easy it is to get pure
haven't haven't looked at it haven't
taken the chemistry
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu